안녕하세요, 제 이름은 데이비드 브라운입니다. 본 수업은 읽기 쓰기 수업입니다.
안녕하세요, 환영합니다. 오늘 어떠신가요?
네, 만나서 반갑습니다.
저도 만나서 반갑습니다. 제 이름은 데이비드입니다. 성함이 어떻게 되시죠?
제 이름은 프란체스코입니다. 만나서 반갑습니다, 데이비드 선생님.
만나서 반갑습니다, 프란체스코 학생. 환영합니다.
월트 휘트먼과 그의 유명한 시에 관한 수업을 선택하신 것으로 알고 있습니다.
"오, 선장님! 나의 선장님!" 읽기 및 쓰기 수업 말이죠. 맞습니까?
네, 맞습니다.
네, 좋습니다.
그럼 에이브러햄 링컨에 대해 조금 말씀드리겠습니다.
아마 '정직한 에이브'라는 별명은 들어보셨을 겁니다. 그는 미국의 제16대 대통령이었습니다.
그는 1865년에 암살당했습니다.
그를 다른 유명한 지도자와 비교해 볼 수도 있겠습니다. 이분이 누구인지 아시겠어요?
네, 프란시스코 모라산입니다.
프란시스코 모라산이요. 네, 두 분이 같지는 않지만, 매우 인기 있는 대통령들이었죠, 그렇죠?
맞습니다. 네.
그래서 우리가 던져볼 질문은 '무엇이 좋은 지도자를 만드는가?'입니다.
잠시 생각해 보시고, 저와 함께 의견을 나눠 이야기해 보도록 하죠.
프란체스코 학생의 생각에는 무엇이 좋은 지도자를 만든다고 보십니까?
네.
적어 내려가야 할까요, 아니면 바로 시작해도 될까요?
네, 바로 말씀하셔도 됩니다.
제 생각에는 영감을 주는 사람일 뿐만 아니라, 언제 행동을 취해야 하는지 아는 사람이라고 생각합니다.
알겠습니다.
네, 동의합니다. 주도력을 가진 사람이겠죠, 그렇죠?
네, 물론입니다.
제 생각에 이 두 지도자 모두 다른 사람들에게 영감을 주고 엄청난 주도력을 발휘한 지도자들이었습니다.
동의합니다.
두 분 모두 몇몇 위대한 자유주의적 개혁에도 관여했습니다.
자, 여기에는 우리의 영어 실력, 특히 읽기와 쓰기, 그리고 전체 수업 동안 대화를 나눌 것이므로 말하기 능력까지 향상시키는 데 도움이 될 수 있는 목록이 있습니다.
이것이 우리 수업의 목표입니다.
여기 첫 번째 것부터 시작해서 수업 목표를 읽어주시겠어요?
네, "오, 선장님! 나의 선장님!"의 역사적 배경을 파악하고 설명하기.
주요 어휘 정의하기.
예를 들면,
엘..레지?
용골, 모진 풍파,
아니면
엘레지입니다.
그리고 시 내부의 확장 은유를 파악하고 설명하기.
확장 은유를 분석하여 선장, 배, 두려운 여정, 그리고 전리품이 무엇을 나타내는지 설명하기.
슬픔과 존경심과 관련하여 시의 분위기를 토론하기.
그리고 토론과 작문 응답을 통해 시에 대한 이해를 표현하기.
네.
아, 그리고 시의 주제인 상실, 리더십, 그리고 국가적 시련을 더 넓은 자유의 개념과 연결하기.
자유인가요?
자유 같은 거요.
네.
아, 자유 같은 거군요.
자, 우리가 할 수 있는 일이 많습니다.
이 모든 것을 다 할 시간이 없을 수도 있지만, 분명 이 시에 대해 음미할 부분이 많습니다.
그리고 음, 월트 휘트먼과 여기의 역사적 배경에 대해서도요.
어휘가 다소 고풍스러울 수 있습니다. 왜냐하면 이 시는 에이브러햄 링컨 암살 직후인 1865년에 쓰였기 때문입니다.
그러니 이 시를 읽을 때 그 점을 염두에 두시기 바랍니다.
이 시에는 배경이 있습니다.
그리고 아마도 좀 더 깊은 무언가에 대해 이야기하고 있을지도 모릅니다.
그래서 우리가 확장 은유라고 할 때, 아시다시피 은유는 A가 B인 경우를 말합니다.
하지만 확장 은유는 어쩌면 한 문단 전체나 글 전체가 무언가를 상징하는 경우를 말합니다.
네.
자, 여기 약간의 역사적 배경이 있습니다.
하지만 먼저, 미국 남북전쟁이나 에이브러햄 링컨에 대해 무엇을 알고 계신가요?
아, '정직한 에이브'라는 별명은 알고 있습니다.
미국 남북전쟁은 특히 노예제와 관련이 있었죠.
제가 틀리지 않았다면, 맞나요?
네.
북부와 남부 사이의 전쟁이었고요.
그리고 에이브러햄 링컨은...
음, 제16대 대통령이라고 하셨는데, 제 생각엔 뭔가...
그가 내린 매우 중요한 결정이 있었던 것 같은데, 정확히 기억이 나질 않네요.
그가 정말로 유명하게 된 계기가 된 무언가가요.
노예 해방 선언 말씀이시군요.
네.
그렇습니다.
훌륭합니다.
미국 남북전쟁과 이 시의 배경에 대해 어느 정도 알고 계시는군요.
미국에서 남북전쟁이 얼마나 중요했는지 아실 겁니다.
단순히 미국에만 영향을 미친 것이 아니라 다른 나라들에도 연쇄적인 파급 효과를 가져왔습니다.
그리고 정말로 많은 태도를 변화시켰습니다.
그리고 남북전쟁이 끝났다고 해서 모든 것이 끝난 것은 아니었습니다.
그리고 여전히 끝나지 않았습니다.
정말로, 우리는 여전히 불평등과 싸우고 있습니다.
우리는 여전히 전 세계적으로 노예제와 관련된 문제들과 싸우고 있습니다.
그리고 진정으로 자유롭다는 것이 무엇을 의미하는지에 대한 이 질문도요.
그리고 그것은 여전히 힘겨운 싸움입니다.
그래서 월트 휘트먼은 1865년에 "오, 선장님! 나의 선장님!"을 썼는데, 바로 두 가지 주요 사건 직후였습니다.
이 부분을 읽어주시겠어요?
물론입니다. 1861년부터 1865년까지 지속된 남북전쟁의 종결.
국가를 분열시킨 잔혹한 분쟁이었습니다.
그리고 1865년 4월 에이브러햄 링컨 대통령의 암살은 남부 연합이 항복한 지 불과 며칠 후였습니다.
링컨은 많은 사람들에게 국가라는 배를 조종한 선장으로 여겨졌습니다.
그 배는... 전쟁이라는 두려운 여정을 헤쳐 나왔습니다.
그래서 우리는 이미 은유의 한 예를 볼 수 있습니다. 국가를 배로, 그가 배를 조종했고, 그가 선장이었던 것이죠.
우리가 읽게 될 이 시에서 말입니다.
여기 에이브러햄 링컨의 또 다른 컬러 사진이 있습니다.
요즘 옛날 사진에 색을 입힐 수 있다는 게 정말 멋지다고 생각합니다.
그리고 실제처럼 보이게 만들죠.
그리고 이것은 신문에서 봤을 법한 장면입니다.
에이브러햄 링컨은 극장에서 총에 맞아 암살당했습니다.
네.
자, 여기 우리가 알아야 할 몇 가지 용어들이 있습니다.
이 어휘들 중 일부는 조금 망설여질 수도 있습니다.
조금 어렵거든요.
서정시, 엘레지, 은유, 그리고 확장 은유가 있습니다.
서정시는 개인적인 감정이나 느낌을 표현하는 시입니다.
일반적으로 1인칭으로 이야기됩니다.
그래서 우리가 곧 읽을 시는 서정시입니다.
그리고 이것, 발음을 기억하세요, 엘레지. 이 부분을 읽어주시겠어요?
네.
진지한 성찰을 담은 시로, 일반적으로 죽은 이를 애도하는 노래입니다.
"오, 선장님! 나의 선장님!"은 에이브러햄 링컨을 위한 엘레지입니다.
그렇습니다.
그래서 우리는 살해된 선장에 대해 이야기하고 있는 것입니다.
그래서 이 시는 정말 깊이가 있습니다.
그리고 그런 의미에서 약간 어둡기도 합니다.
전쟁이 끝났을 때의 감정을 상상해 보셔야 합니다.
전쟁이 끝났을 때의 감정은 안도감일 수 있습니다.
안도감도 있었겠지만, 동시에 큰 슬픔도 있었을 것입니다.
잃어버린 생명들을 되돌릴 수는 없습니다.
일어난 일을 되돌릴 수는 없습니다.
일어난 일은 이미 일어난 일입니다.
은유가 있습니다. 단어나 구가 적용되는 화법이죠.
즉, 한 가지가 다른 것일 때, 그리고 그것의 확장인 확장 은유가 있습니다.
이 부분을 읽어주시겠어요?
네.
여러 줄의 글이나 작품 전체에 걸쳐 전개되는 은유입니다.
훌륭합니다.
자, 첫 번째 낭독입니다.
이 첫 부분은 제가 읽겠습니다.
이것이 어떻게 들리는지 귀 기울여 들어보시기 바랍니다.
모두의 시선이 안정된 용골을 따르는 동안,
배는 암울하고도 대담하게 나아가네.
하지만 오, 심장아, 심장아, 심장아!
오, 흐르는 붉은 핏방울이여,
나의 선장님이 갑판 위에 쓰러져 있네, 차갑고 싸늘하게.
그래서 우리는 용골이 있는 배의 이미지를 보게 됩니다.
배의 특정 부분이죠, 그렇죠?
암울하고 대담한 배.
이 어두운 배가 들어오는 것을 보게 됩니다.